a Texas family is threatening legal
action against their school district
after their teenage son was told he
could not walk at graduation because of
his hair
the barbers Hill school district told
DeAndre Arnold that his long dreadlocks
violate its dress code
DeAndre is being forced to either cut
his hair or face an in-school suspension
the Arnold family says this is about
race
well more via franca is in Mont Belvieu
Texas where this all started
Omar good morning does DeAndre his hair
violate a school policy is that really a
policy it says you can't have dreadlocks
under this policy yes now DeAndre wears
his hair up it's not in his eyes and
it's not below his collar but the policy
was rewarded in December and the
superintendent told us it doesn't matter
if boys wear their hair up or if they
wear their hair down what matters is the
length it cannot be a certain length and
now the family is pleading with the
district for an exception this isn't how
I wanted to remember my senior year at
all DeAndre Arnold's final semester at
barbers Hill High School was supposed to
be filled with memories that would stay
with him forever it's always up and kind
of off of you know all the regulations
but an issue over a hairstyle he's been
wearing since the seventh grade is
putting a damper on his senior year his
mom thinks it's a black and white issue
there's no people of color on the school
board so I get it they think that they
don't understand about his hair it's his
hair style a distraction or does it stop
him from learning in any way not a bit
he has good grades I don't get calls
about that I don't get calls cuz he's
disrespectful anything other than his
hair at least once a week for sure
I'm getting called to the office above
my hair what's impeding your learning
more you getting called to the office or
your hair me getting called to the
office every every week I can count on
it every school district in the nation
has a dress code I don't think you can
go to school in your underwear
superintendent Gary Poole says the dress
code which has been in place for 30
years only limits hair length not style
we'd love to see DeAndre back in class
and there's no way we would inhibit him
from grad
waiting but we are gonna be fair to the
6200 other kids that have to comply not
the same policy they said he'll be able
to graduate but he just couldn't walk
right I'm a parent you're a parent hey
you want the walking you want the
walking you've put in the work you saw
your peers you're gonna take that away
from him
I mean it's unfair is it a look is it a
cultural thing is it a heritage thing
the culture really plays a role in this
because you know being around my dad and
stuff and around his people I really
seen something that I wanted to you know
take part in and you know the dreadlocks
or the locks that was just something I
really like just last year California
became the first state to ban
discrimination against black students
and employees over their natural
hairstyles New York and New Jersey have
since signed similar bills into law
Jerry Monroe is a community activist
working with the family when you heard
they wanted him to cut his hair and
they're saying it's a dress code thing
you believe that no we're located in one
of the most racist counties in the state
of Texas you think it's all I don't
think that no I know
let me play devil's advocate here are
you willing to cut your hair no what I'm
willing to do is just get out of the
situation how about going to a different
school is something like that if I had
to because I'm not gonna sit here and
deal with this like I'm a senior about
to graduate I'm not to go to college I
don't need any added stress on me
deandre has been getting a lot of
support from his friends and from
another deandre Houston Texans star wide
receiver DeAndre Hopkins who tweeted
never cut your locks that DeAndre tells
me he gets good grades he's never really
in trouble at school at all
and he's looking forward to go to
college but today they say they are
gonna be looking for another high school
to graduate from Anthony that's
heartbreaking he says he gets good
grades he does he's a good student he's
a good person
isn't that what should matter we people
need to be reminding in the black
culture your hair dreadlocks are
unacceptable they are not an unusual
hairdo it just drives me
crazy when I see stories like this
insulting Anthony I understand what's
disruptive about it I mean the
administrators dead I think that well
you can't go to school and your
underwear that's not he's not he's just
last time I checked he was wearing
clothes and why do I dig in on this
issue of all issues just let it go now
he has to change schools makes no sense